PARTICIPATE AS THE NEWEST MEMBER
OF THE SUPREME COURT.
MY OPENING MONOLOGUE IS STRAIGHT
AHEAD BUT FIRST JOINING US NOW,
GUIDED THE WHOLE PROCESS AS
PROMISED, SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS WITH US.
I DID NOTICE A LITTLE BIT OF A
TEMPER TANTRUM AND THERE WERE A
LOT OF THREATS GOING ON ABOUT
PACKING THE COURT AND ENDING THE
LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER.
AMNESTY, A LOT OF POWER GRABS.
NOT EASY.
>> [LAUGHS]
THE INTERNET IS MELTING DOWN.
THERE IS AN ABSOLUTE DESIRE TO
TAKE ME OUT.
LindseyGraham.com.
I NEED YOUR HELP NOW MORE THAN
EVER.
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU’RE
THE BIGGEST WINNER TONIGHT.
YOU HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
CONSERVATIVE WOMAN WHO
UNDERSTANDS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN MY JOB AND BEING A
JUDGE.
SHE’S ONE OF THE MOST HIGHLY
EDUCATED PEOPLE EVER TO GO ON
THE COURT.
SHE IS NOT FROM HARVARD.
SHE IS NOT FROM YALE.
SHE IS A NORMAL PERSON.
SHE’S GOING TO DO AN AWESOME
JOB.
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE BIG WINNER TONIGHT IS
CONSERVATIVE WOMEN.
TO ALL THOSE CONSERVATIVE WOMEN
WHO GO THROUGH FOR BEING
CONSERVATIVE, WHO GET BEAT UP BY
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA FOR
EMBRACING YOUR FAITH BY
BEING PRO-LIFE, BEING
TRADITIONAL AND YOUR FAMILY
STRUCTURE, YOUR WINNER TONIGHT.
THERE’S A SEAT AT THE TABLE FOR
YOU.
THIS IS NOT A GLASS CEILING
BEING BROKEN.
IT’S A CONCRETE BARRIER BEING
BROKEN.
AMY BARRETT REPRESENTS EVERY
ASPIRATION OF A YOUNG
CONSERVATIVE WOMAN.
SHE IS GOING TO DO AWESOME.
I CANNOT WAIT FOR HER TO BE ON
THE SUPREME COURT TOMORROW.
>> Tucker: IN MANY WAYS, I
SUSPECT, I’VE BEEN WATCHING THIS
PROCESS.
WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED WITH
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
THE DEMOCRATS, HAD IT NOT BE SO
CLOSE TO AN ELECTION, WOULD’VE
SMEARED, SLANDERED, BESMIRCHED.
THEY WOULD’VE DONE WHAT THEY DID
TO KAVANAUGH.
AND JUSTICE THOMAS WHO WILL
ADMINISTER THE OATH TONIGHT AND
WHAT THEY DID TO ROBERT BORK.
IF THEY COULD, THEY WOULD HAVE.
INSTEAD, I WANT TO GET YOUR
TAKE.
WE ARE GOING TO PACK THE COURTS.
EVERYTHING IS ON THE TABLE.
END THE LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER.
D.C., PUERTO RICO STATEHOOD.
FULL ON AMNESTY.
I ASSUME SOMETHING OF VALUE.
THEY WOULD APPRECIATE VOTES IN
FUTURE ELECTIONS.
THAT TO ME NOW SPEAKS OF
ONE-PARTY RULE AND THEY’LL DO
IT.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> THEY’RE GOING TO DO IT.
THE ONLY REASON THEY WON’T DO IT
IS THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE STOP
THEM.
WE MUST MAINTAIN CONTROL WITHIN
THE UNITED STATES SENATE.
YOU HAVE JONI ERNST ON THE
BALLOT FROM IOWA.
YOU’VE GOT MARTHA McSALLY, TWO
GREAT CONSERVATIVE WOMEN.
YOU GOT SUSAN COLLINS IS BEEN
JUST TERRIFIC SENATOR FROM
MAINE.
HELP JUDGE KAVANAUGH, HELPED US
WITH THE TAX CUTS.
HELP ALL OF US.
WE CANNOT TURN OVER THE ENTIRE
GOVERNMENT TO THIS RADICAL LEFT.
SCHUMER’S SPEECH TONIGHT WAS
DISGUSTING.
HE’S THE GUY THAT STARTED THE
FILIBUSTER WITH BUSH 43.
HE’S A GUY ALONG WITH
SENATOR KENNEDY WHO DECLARED WAR
ON ALL THINGS CONSERVATIVE.
IT IS ALITO, KAVANAUGH, THOMAS,
BORK.
IT’S NOT THE PROCESS.
THEY TRIED TO DESTROY
JUDGE KAVANAUGH’S LIFE.
AMY BARRETT IS PROBABLY A
BENEFICIARY FROM THE KAVANAUGH
HEARINGS.
IT BLEW UP IN THEIR FACE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HATED WHAT
THEY DID TO KAVANAUGH, SO I
THINK THEY WERE MORE RESPECTFUL
TO JUDGE BARRETT.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
THE INTERNET IS ON FIRE TONIGHT.
THEY ARE RAISING MONEY LIKE
CRAZY TO TAKE BACK THE SENATE
AND BEAT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HELP ME.
EVERYBODY TRICKLE HELP EVERYBODY
I JUST NAMED.
LindseyGraham.com.
MY OPPONENTS RAISED A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
THE MOST IN THE UNITED STATES,
HISTORY OF THE SENATE.
LET’S ALL FIGHT BACK TOGETHER.
LET’S CELEBRATE THIS IS SO
PIVOTAL.
CONSERVATIVES NEED TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT COURT PACKING WOULD MEAN.
D.C., PUERTO RICO STATEHOOD
WOULD MEAN.
WHAT ALL OF THESE, WE’VE BEEN
GIVEN THE ONE MINUTE.
WHITE HOUSE SWEARING IN OF ANY
COUNTY BARRETT, THE SWEARING-IN
WILL BE DONE BY JUSTICE
CLARENCE THOMAS.
IF YOU NEVER READ HIS BOOK, IT’S
A GREAT BOOK.
I TELL EVERYBODY ALL THE TIME.
HIGHER TACKETT TAXES, AMNESTY.
WHEN I SAY IT’S THE TIPPING
POINT OF ALL TIPPING POINT
ELECTIONS, YOU’RE RIGHT.
IT’S YOUR RACE.
IT’S EVERYBODY.
CORY GARDNER, PURDUE,
MITCH McCONNELL.
SUSAN COLLINS WHO I DISAGREE
WITH ON THIS VOTE.
IT’S ALL IN THE BALANCE BECAUSE
THEY WILL DO IT.
WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN TO THE --
>> NUMBER ONE, THEY ARE GOING TO
TAKE THE NUMBER NINE AND
EXPANDED TO PROBABLY 13 TO WIPE
OUT THE CONSERVATIVE MAJORITY.
THEY WILL PACKET WITH LIBERALS.
THAT MEANS THE COURT LOSES ITS
INDEPENDENCE.
THEY WILL DO AWAY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER.
THEY ARE GOING TO DO AWAY WITH
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE WHICH
MEANS NEW YORK AND CALIFORNIA
PICK THE PRESIDENT IN
PERPETUITY.
IOWA, SOUTH CAROLINA, ARIZONA
WON’T COUNT ANYMORE.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE OPEN
BORDERS AND FREE HEALTH CARE FOR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
ALL OF THEM RAISED THEIR HAND.
THEY WILL TURN THIS COUNTRY FROM
A FREE ENTERPRISE NATION TO A
SOCIALIST NATION.
FROM THE LAW AND ORDER NATION TO
CHAOS.
THEY WILL REWARD THE MOST
RADICAL AGENDA IN THE HISTORY OF
THE COUNTRY THAT’S TRYING TO
TAKE US ALL OUT.
WE’VE GOT A CHANCE TO MAKE
HISTORY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE FOUR MORE
YEARS --
>> Sean: THAT MUSIC MEANS THE
FIRST LADY.
>> THE BIG GUY.